er soll das halteseil von einem
baumstamm gestell im dann in rüder fonds
durchtrennt haben daraufhin krachte das
gebilde in einem bereich zusammen in dem
mehrere polizeibeamte standen sie
konnten sich gerade noch so in
sicherheit bringen die baumstämme
krachte dann gegen einen bagger nun
fahnden die ermittler nach dem
unbekannten mann der tat vorwurf
versuchter totschlag tätlicher angriff
auf vollstreckungsbeamte und
sachbeschädigung der vorfall ereignete
sich am 23 november im nördlichen
bereich des dann oder forst
auch ein 51 jähriger baggerfahrer wurde
fast von den stämmen getroffen er blieb
unverletzt weil die sicherheits kabine
seines baggers den bäumen standhielt
mehrere zeugen hatten beobachtet dass
der gesuchte das halteseil des baumstamm
gestellt vor dem umstürzen durchtrennt
hatte die staatsanwaltschaft gießen hat
nun ein ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet
der mann ist 1 meter 85 groß schlank hat
langes haar und einen oberlippen- und
kinnbart sowie blaue augen er spricht
englisch mit osteuropäischem akzent
hinweise nimmt die polizei hessen per
telefon entgegen seit mehr als einem
jahr protestieren umweltschützer in
hessen gegen den umstrittenen ausbau der
a 49 zwischen gießen und kassel
die autobahn soll dort durch ein
waldgebiet führen
der bau der autobahn soll laut dem
landkreis vogelsberg im september 2021
beginnen derzeit laufen vorbereitende
arbeiten dabei sollen bis februar 2021
zunächst 27 hektar wald gerodet werden
die rodungen begannen vor einigen wochen
und werden nach wie vor von protesten
begleitet
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren